oui
[Musique]
bienvenue dans la grande interview notre
invité est charles blé goudé
l'ex-ministre de la jeunesse ivoirien
définitivement acquitté le 31 mars en
appel par la cour pénale internationale
avec laurent gbagbo l'ex président de la
côte d'ivoire
les deux ex dirigeants ivoiriens étaient
accusés de crimes contre l'humanité lors
de la crise post électorale de 2010 2011
charles blé goudé bonjour merci d'avoir
accepté cette grande interview sur rtl
france sept ans après votre
transfèrement à la lfp est donc
confirmée en appel votre acquittement
prononcé en janvier 2019 est-ce que ce
non lieu il vous donne droit à un
dédommagement l'indemnité si oui combien
il dépasse de 6 et d'amour le stand
activement ensuite on testé par le
procureur est confirmée à la chambre
d'appel
je suis je suis content que non
durabilité et de la vie que finalement
je ne les guérit pas alain progéniture
elle non assermentés du sein une zone de
concitoyens et que je ne serais pas là
de ma génération
combien cela me rapporte il veut pas
parler en termes de matériel nadal
le préjudice que j'ai subi il est plus
que morin parce que une capitale
mon image ma dignité et je suis content
que j'ai été rétabli la vérité c'est le
plus important tout le reste mais offre
mes avocats m'ont conseil et tous ceux
qui sont menés que de défense ont le
temps de faire le point de tout ce qui
rentre dans le camp de leur travail
sadourny selon les textes de la cpi de
vous remercie confirmé qu'il y a il y
aura une indemnité un dédommagement on
en est pas là cela fait à peine de 48
heures que la décision a été prise
permettez-moi de au moins nous réjouit
de cette décision
qu'est ce donc la conséquence je le dis
que des avocats mussolini haut et fort
mais je pense qu'une fois que cela est
fait tu venais j'insiste là dessus c'est
plus morale autre chose c'est aussi
important pour moi
merci quel sens donnez vous aux préfets
que vous ont livré la cpi et ces
derniers procureur luis moreno campo et
fatou bensouda que ce soit louise ocampo
qui a commencé ce dossier où on a moins
fatou bensouda petit j'ai beaucoup de
respect qui était dans le cadre de leur
travail
ce sont des procureurs le rôle de
culture et ses deux pouces et lâches et
des pouvez ensuite ces allégations
chablis goody et est il celui qui a
commis le crime en côte d'ivoire j'ai
été transféré à la cpi à leur donnant
les juges après plusieurs années de
procédure
une longue procédure ont estimé que ma
responsabilité n'est pas engagée à la
clim
si on lui à la suite des élections dans
ce pays en 2010 2011 mais je passe qui
leur revient au niveau de la cour de
continuer de chercher qui sont les
auteurs de ces crimes parce que fait
clair il ya eu des crimes dans le pays
increased by des mots il est orphelin
il ya eu deux veuves et il est exilé
niveau des dommages
la société ivoirienne de randonnée
combien déliquescence le fossé jusqu'au
but profond que s'est il passé que s'est
il passé
quelle est la responsable des décharges
acteurs politiques je me réjouis que la
mienne était définitivement situer au
niveau international et à la suite d'un
bris à la façon
vous êtes libres maintenant de vous
exprimer puisque cette procédure elle
est close maintenant la cpi est ce que
c'est une juridiction impartiale
indépendante puisque en afrique vous
savez qu'il ya des voix qui s'élèvent
pour lui reprocher de ne juger que des
personnalités africaines dont la
première a été d'ailleurs laurent gbagbo
l'ex chef de l'état ivoirien a quitté
avec vous oui en effet nous avons été
transférés ici nous sommes soumis à la
justice internationale
nous connaissons même pas le juge
quitte à charge de notre dossier du
début à la fin je me rappelle pas une
seule fois qu'on est l'occasion d'un
bond le mois de mars il est là mais ses
juges ils ont fait leur travail est la
conclusion à laquelle sont arrivés au
lit tous c'est vrai la procédure était
longue
nadal l éloigner de nos familles l'appli
vie de beaucoup de choses avec deux ans
en exil jusqu'à ce qu'il soit arrêté
hélas aujourd'hui blues la bnf y avait 6
ans céline dion lors de 17 ans nous
connaissent
prenez à peine voilà le plus important
qu'ils ont pu mais nous sommes des
acteurs politiques
c'est normal que quand on est acteur que
de votre responsabilités soient situées
doit-on juger la cpi ma vision n'a pas
changé à ma prise de parole lors de la
première comparution jeudi et les gens
pensaient que je présentais que j'étais
content d'être là affectivement
responsabilités soient situées
quelqu'un citoyenne quels qu'ils soient
qui est suspecté par la cpi décline
venir la cpi subi un procès ici nous
sommes un blé goudé va déposer une
question tout à l'heure qui va payer
finalement pour les 3000 morts hans et
un bilan de l'onu lors de cette crise
post électorale de 2010
2011 est ce que la cpi par exemple doit
s'ouvrir à nouveau dossier à l'ouest sur
les tueries à l'ouest qui pourrait
impliquer par exemple les forces pro
ouattara à l'époque
si un citoyen et à la cpi s'il est
reconnu coupable il a condamné s'il a
reconnu innocent il le pari
je viens d'être connu une hausse à la
suite de la procédure
du temps de la compétence du procureur
qui était à la recherche des auteurs la
crise et qui nous a pas trouvé à
l'attention de bengo jablines des tweets
elle conduit les enquêtes
elle a des atouts elle a déclaré les
yeux du monde sont rivés ce n ous et
collaborateurs aux sanglots j'ai appelé
que elle parle des choix est celui qui
va le remplacer le toit continue de
travailler parce que la mesure aurait
besoin de savoir
cela dit moi je ne suis pas procureur
dans la vie chacun un son multi et ses
fonctions on y suit politique
on m'a supporté des crimes contre
l'humanité j'ai été innocenté je ne vais
pas le rôle de madame bensouda à sa
place ou de ce rituel la remplacer jd
fêtant les autorités ivoiriennes pour
elle et fait rentrer laurent gbagbo qui
est âgé de 75 ans et il lui dispose d'un
passeport
croyez vous qu'elles feront de même vous
feront faire non moi je suis venu ici
parce que je souhaitais le président
gbagbo
il aide aussi ont été joints on a dit
chris huhne bras droit de bien drôles
gbagbo sait qu'il noir sur blanc dans
tous les documents tous nous accuser ce
qu'on a payé on appelait le document
contenant léchage aller le dcc on peut
non pas laisser entrer le plan d'eau
lambeaux il sait châble décide
j'espère unis en villégiature supermini
tourisme chez lui pour la même affaire
et moi je voulais
invite à aller en maison je pense que
les autorités ivoiriennes à si on sait
qu'il faut pour poser l'acte qu'il faut
l'adhésion que les sept pages l'asseoir
tournis je place toute ma confiance vous
et laurent gbagbo vous et laurent gbagbo
fait l'objet de poursuites judiciaires
en côte d'ivoire en ce qui vous concerne
la justice ivoirienne vous reproche des
crimes commis durant les barrages
d'auto-défense en 2010 et 2011 quelles
sont vos chances d'être investie est ce
qu'il ya eu des discussions dans ce sens
avec les autorités de votre pays
il n'y a pas encore eu des discussions
et moi je vous le dit nico qui peut le
plus peut le moins
si celui qui le soutiennent écoutez je
suis ici a eu des passeports et que tout
est en train d'être mises en oeuvre qui
rentre il n'y a aucune raison comment je
reste ici
j'irai en côte d'ivoire est le plein ils
ont d'abord parce que nous sommes venus
ici pour les mêmes raisons et je lance
encore cet appel au président alassane
ouattara et à toute son équipe
je leur demande et je souhaite qu'ils
fassent légiste a faim il a besoin que
nous viendrons à bout - ou bus sont
rentrés chez eux c'est à lanmeur la côte
d'ivoire a besoin des salons les ai
vraiment besoin de tourner la page et
c'est la responsabilité des dirigeants
dé prendre les yeux et son incapacité et
l'autorité nécessaire pour le faire
et s'il n'y a pas d'amnistié c'est
alassane ouattara vous refuse l'amnestie
est-ce que vous rentrerez quand même au
pays pour affronter la justice ans j'ai
déjà affronté la justice internationale
mais je ne suis pas dans les schémas
chaotique mon pays a besoin de paix et
je ne veux pas aller pourquoi d'ivoire
c'est la base du conflit alors que je
suis venu ici cela va des confitures et
bâtissent une base des jeunes ils
parlent quand ils voient confrontées les
autorités ivoiriennes
je vais plutôt partie sur la base de
négociation qui puisse faciliter la paix
dans mon pays parce que les
confrontations ont des limites c'est la
désolation et ce sont les idées qui me
met à chaque cri fou c'est pourquoi je
ne suis pas d'accord souvent car les
avait pas de marques de tout non
l'écurie tous pour vos démos ils sont
plutôt contre cette page là et que le
seul qui ait lieu ces thématiques de
paix qui puisse l ensemble des six mois
vous serez quand même la carte de
l'apaisement est ce que ce sera
suffisant pour éviter l'exil comme
guillaume soro l'ex chef rebelle ex
proche d'alassane ouattara vous vous
êtes rapprocher tous les deux lui les
persona non grata vous le savez en côte
d'ivoire sous le coup de la justice
aussi madame monsieur je ne suis pas je
suis charles blé goudé gdc de la cpi 17
pouces a été fait et j'étais le communes
non au peuple innocent je baptise peu à
peu le jour où laisser vos légumes sur
le cerveau de plateau ou de malgré sa
responsable si vous ne craignez pas de
subir le même sort qu'aux guillaume soro
actuellement des trains ont sûrement
trouvé ici trouver ici je ne saurais
seulement ici sa frappe et me voilà et
je ne veux pas jouer les couleurs mais
je pense que je suis
ce que j'ai vécu à qui que ce soit je
souhaite que la fin de la fois deux
voies se retournant je ne crains pas de
civilisation que you so parce que je ne
suis pas du ruisseau je lance un appel
aux autorités de mon pays je leur
demande de faire une sorte de facile dès
mon retour en côte d'ivoire parce que je
souhaite en tourner cette page là le
peson matin l'autorité et il a la
capacité et il avait promis lors de sa
campagne présidentielle que une fois que
le nom d'un mouvement nous avons fini
avec la justice internationale ou kara
juste internationale aura fini avec nous
il fait en sorte de faciliter notre
retour nous y sommes et moi je lui fais
confiance et je voudrais pas du tout
mettre la pression et je dis aller
chercher des arguments qui n'ont rien à
voir pour le contexte la côte d'ivoire
n'en a pas terminé avec les violences
puisque est une des violences
électorales dernièrement 85 morts des
centaines de blessés selon un bilan des
autorités ce serait beaucoup plus selon
l'opposition
est-ce qu'il faut enquêter là aussi
puisque votre pays n'en a pas terminé
avec les rivalités politiques les
violences électorales post électorale
c'est il faut faire plus tôt c'est de
poser les bases d'une balise d'une
démocratie avec des règles consensuelles
qui puisse faire en sorte qu'une
élection n'est plus par limite avec la
menace d'une guerre c'est comme si part
annoncé une guerre c'est plutôt assure
atif une solution à redonner à la côte
d'ivoire d'institutions fortes
des hommes qui sont conscients de leurs
responsabilités
derrière mais payés à charles blé goudé
je suis donc à nouveau dit que tout cela
poutou des élections comme on devait de
marquer les il ne se lève pas pour se
battre pour des sacs chaque élection que
il y à des conflits qui susurre des mots
c'est pourquoi je dis il faut poser les
deux moustiques madame il faut que la
force de la nation puisse s'asseoir
j'ai appelé les assises nationales je
m'appelle encore à cela c'est seulement
en discuter un échange ne font pas les
idées
acceptant de gilles ragot d'ivoire dans
le respect de nos différences que le
groupe n'hésite pas et faire en sorte
d'éviter les violences et le toit
charles blé goudé merci pour cette
grande interview accordée à rtl france
merci à vous de l'avoir suivi une grande
interview que vous pouvez retrouver en
replay sur nos réseaux sociaux et notre
site
rt france point tva très bientôt
[Musique]